yeah all right happy Tuesday
happy Tuesday everybody another
beautiful audience
so how do you know when you're in the
middle of some form of Hysteria
well if people say you're crazy for
pointing it out you see this you see
this now with gender assignment surgery
for kids proponents claim it's about the
child's happiness so how dare you
suggest that cutting up kids like a
Thanksgiving turkey is harmful
it's page one of the gaslighting
handbook you're nuts and not them but
thankfully this delusion is now eroding
in the UK a gender identity Clinic was
shut down after allegedly fast-tracking
miners gender transitions a new book
claims the facility ignored evidence
that 97.5 percent of the children
seeking sex changes had autism
depression or other problems that might
have explained their unhappiness
because as we all know there's no better
treatment for autism depression and
unhappiness than putting your privates
in a blender
I'm sorry if a child wants to change
genders no doctor should say hey well
you're the boss
that's like telling an anorexic maybe
you do need to lose a few pounds and
then handing her diet pills
a whistleblower says children who might
not have been trans were treated as
collateral damage by clinicians who
label doubters transphobic
sorry if 97.5 percent are collateral
damage you got worse aim than Alec
Baldwin
sometimes kids
sometimes kids as young as 10 were sent
on this path
I mean where did these creeps go to med
school Epstein Island
so what happens when all these abused
children grow up into regretful adults
you know beyond auditioning for the open
seat on The View
they should sue the hospitals to force
this stuff on them I mean you take a
surgeon who leaves a sponge in your
spleen to court so why not one who
leaves your weenie in a sink
they should pay or it's going to keep on
happening
but whistleblowers are starting to blow
their whistles PE teacher she has a
whistle Jessica Tapia in California says
she was fired for not complying with her
school district's gender policies citing
her Christian faith once again that old
pescule Jesus ruins the party
apparently they wanted her to lie to
parents about their kids gender
transitions under their private policy
privacy policy a privacy policy that's
the perfect wedge between kids and their
parents but since when has someone
saying hey don't tell your parents about
our obsession with your genitals has
ever been the good guy
here's Jessica
I also found out unique to my condition
as a PE teacher that I I have to allow I
was told I need to allow trans students
into the locker room that really caught
me off guard and I clarified with them
are you are you telling me I need to let
male genitals into a locker room and
they said yes
she lost her job for sounding the alarm
in one of her school district well they
say they take employees religious
beliefs seriously but also the students
right to privacy it's out bogus
religious beliefs shouldn't matter first
an atheist should be as discussed just
as disgusted by this phenomenon as any
Christian or Muslim or Scientologist you
don't need the Bible to tell you this is
wrong just a 14 year old daughter with a
handlebar mustache
[Laughter]
meanwhile the Missouri AG is probing
disturbing whistleblower claims that a
transgender Clinic harmed hundreds of
kids Jamie Reed is a left-wing
self-identified queer Woman married to a
trans man
I'd love to see the figures on top of
that wedding cake
the blower is calling out the Washington
University transgender Center at the St
Louis Children's Hospital where she
worked as a case manager Reid alleges
statutes experimental drugs on kids
Distributing puberty puberty blockers
and cross-sex hormones and also use
these drugs without parental consent
meaning that if you gave your depressed
son steroids to feel like a he-man
they'd arrest you but your depressed
daughter they'll pump her full of enough
testosterone to make Lance Armstrong's
nut grow back
thank you
sorry
but this stuff would make Himmler blush
Reed also says that this led some kids
to attempt suicide in the center never
stopped Doling out hormones you know
forget about Do no harm they didn't stop
when they knew they were doing harm
looks like that meanwhile Washington U
says it's alarmed by the allegations and
they should be because it appears The
Jig Is up parents know what they've been
up to and there's going to be hell to
pay and that's one bill they can't pass
on to anyone else meanwhile Reed also
has evidence that Missouri unlawfully
build taxpayers to fund all of this
where do these people get their balls
you know what I don't want to know
[Applause]
as the colonies oh this appears Morgan
uncensored on Fox station Piers Morgan
she's so wise that owls call her for
career advice author of the social
justice Warrior handbook Lisa de
Pasquale
[Applause]
the only thing older than his act is his
wardrobe post a fox Across America Jimmy
Fila
and like day old coffee she's ice cold
and bitter Fox News contributor captive
cheers welcome to the show I feel like I
just saw you you did just save me on the
five but um you know you're never enough
of me right that's true I never have
enough appears thank you yes I think
that should be your motto no no you know
what I I have a feeling we're going to
look back at this era as the way we we
looked at the 80s during that kind of
like child molestation scare remember
and they were all the daycare centers
that people are gonna like what were we
thinking is it as crazy as it is here
over there where's Clinic that you
mentioned is it was in London and the
extraordinary thing but this is actually
widespread with this whole Work World We
Now live in is that everybody knew this
was wrong what was going on in that
clinic everybody had a sense people were
trying to get into it to report on it to
expose what was happening to these poor
kids but anyone who tried to do that was
promptly branded transphobic right you
were a bigot if you didn't go along with
this and acquiesce to every part of it
there was something wrong with you and
it turned out actually no everyone's
suspicions were right yeah actually what
was going on in there was what was wrong
and had to change and this is the weapon
that the woke Brigade used isn't it is
that whenever you raise say the
transgender in sport debate when you see
a six foot four inch former male
competing against women in a swimming
pool and beat them up by 50 seconds if
you say well that's not fair is it
that's wrong it's unequal you're a
bigger right you're a transphobe and so
it goes on it's the weaponizing of these
issues makes it almost impossible to
debate and anyone who tries to JK
Rowling and others who've tried to
defend women's rights in all this or
children's rights as in the case of the
Tavistock Clinic you become the
weaponized person you become the one who
is attacked when in fact what you just
read was one of the bravest things I've
heard on television in the world well
because finally finally someone's
actually saying the truth about this
stuff this is this is child abuse yeah
what's been going on it's the job of
adults to protect children not to expose
them to what has been going on it is
crazy
freezing
it's crazy Lisa because I hate children
and here I am fighting for them I
despise those monsters but I'm speaking
of you know what drives me crazy is the
phrase puberty blockers
for 300 000 years we all went through
puberty I think you should just go
through it right and then see what
happens after but how can you put it's
like saying you know I'm going to put
off growing hair right it's not like
delaying your driver's license at some
point you're gonna have to do this
that's what I thought
well now what's interesting is there's
so many things you know that's been
brought up before that you need to be
over 18 to do like get a tattoo or get
some other cosmetic surgery
um and you know there are rare cases
when the parents can allow it but in
this case you know there's tons of
storytellers out there that I really
wish would be more public I know that
they have this obstacle the media but
there's detransitioners there's
feminists like JK Rowling who have a
problem with this there's gays there's
parents there there's lots of people
that can tell their stories on this and
I I agree with peers that your monologue
was was great oh I thank you you know
what I like these kind of guests
after getting all that abuse from Tyrus
and Cat it's nice tough love yeah you
know I wish you would transition yeah
something like appealing
[Laughter]
what do you make of this uh what do you
make of this trend do you think that
finally like there's a flashlight being
shown yeah no I think this is going to
end at a bunch of lawsuits and someone's
going to make a courtroom drama called
12 Angry them hahaha
that was actually a good joke come on
man stick with me here is the scam of
why this has been going on from word one
and we know this to be true there's two
motives here one the clinics make a ton
of money off the surgery and ultimately
the meds that come with having a
lifelong patient which in its own is
barbaric and Reckless two is they're
kind of manufacturing a new Civil Rights
Movement where they're trying to advance
all of their legislation around anybody
who opposes what we want is going to
spark a wave of suicides but we know
it's not about the trans people and
their well-being why because of our
friend Caitlyn Jenner if you remember
the Caitlyn Jenner story she got on the
cover of Vanity Fair day one they were
like she's beautiful anyone who doesn't
think so is a monster we're gonna kill
your dog we're gonna dox your family day
two ESPN courage award she's wonderful
she's Brave anybody who's not okay with
this is a loser they should be fired day
three she goes I'm a republican they
were like her get her out of here
screw you Bruce Wheaties gave me the I
don't like you yeah and there it went
yeah
but you know this I know this everybody
here knows this it's never been about
tolerance or inclusion it's always about
whether or not you're a Democrat and you
can read further if you ask a black
conservative or a female conservative
who happens to be running for president
none of the rules apply to those
marginalized groups you just gave me a
great idea okay we we have men who
identify as women while holding on to
their genitalia and participating in
sports what if you as a Republican or a
conservative transitioned into being a
Democrat while holding all of your
beliefs
lethal that makes that makes some sense
but at the same it doesn't
cat what do you think you can ignore
everything I just said I did
uh I don't know I mean obviously the way
this happens is it's like the most
contentious issue is the trans issue so
I think the with any contentious issue
the best thing to do is kind of take the
contentious part out of it and if you
just say in any kind of medical
situation if there is a treatment that
can have lasting effects on a person
then you want to really be sure that
that's what you want to do uh for
example you don't give someone chemo if
you're not sure if they have cancer or
not because chemo could have lasting
effects so I feel like if you explain it
like that to people they really you have
to agree that's no way to not agree
that's a brilliant way of putting it but
oh I am glad I came back but if you do
say that I wonder if you're working at
one of these clinics they'd go don't say
that because they're no because that
makes too much sense but also also it
comes back to this thing of
self-identity right this is the era we
live in where you can identify whatever
you want to be okay Republican Democrat
good example we just had a case in
Scotland quite unbelievable oh the
rapist have you done this yeah we did
this story rapist identifies female to
get into women's male rapist who was
married to a woman for many years who
said he's a total scam artist gets
convicted of raping two women and at his
trial he suddenly puts his hand up and
says oh by the way I'm called Isla I'm a
woman yeah you can't send me to a Men's
prison where he would be badly treated I
want to go into a women's prison where
there are fresh targets for him to
attack and he actually got into a
woman's prison pretending to be a woman
the first minister of Scotland Nicholas
Durden just had to resign over the
fiorari that this all caused but this is
where Limitless self-identity takes you
in a society yeah if you have no it's
supposed to have some societal rules
there's no restrictions anymore
restrictions are actually bigoted right
any kind of any kind of like limits a
racist last word to you cat did you have
anything else you wanted to say I think
I pretty much covered it okay good
excellent work there you can take the
rest of this moment thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else